foreign
you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my little movie review Series so I
kind of figure most of y'all watching
this y'all are all horror nerds like I
am right no shame
um and as you probably know this has
probably happened to you every now and
then uh you just find yourself in the
mood for some real just pure
unadulterated
1970s Limburger cheese man you just want
something super super cheesy from the
1970s
so uh being in one of those moods myself
this week has happens from time to time
I decided I was gonna you know toddle on
over to shutter and check out this 1970s
flick I knew it was on there because I'd
seen it previously and I kind of been
curious to see it because this was a
movie I mean I saw a lot of these kind
of real cheesy movies from the 70s but
this one had somehow kind of passed me
by back in the day even though I had
heard about it so the movie that we're
going to be talking about is the rather
outlandish 1978 Opus if you want to call
it that known as the Manitou
now this is actually based on a novel by
Graham masterton and he's a British
author I mean he's very very famous in
the horror Community this was actually
the manatee was actually his debut novel
uh it came out two years prior to the
movie coming out
now the movie version uh this was sadly
the last movie that was directed by a
guy named William girdler who actually
died in a helicopter crash like before
this movie even came out like after he
was done working on it so William
gerdler actually made only nine movies
you know over the course of his career
because obviously it was uh cut short
sadly
um but he kind of made things in several
different genres he made a couple black
exploitation movies he made Abby which
was kind of like the quote-unquote black
exploitation like Exorcist ripoff that
was from 1974. he made one called Shiba
baby which I think had Pam Grier in it
um he did a three on a mate hook which
was kind of like I think it's about
um was it about Ed Gein I think it was
like Loosely based on Ed Gein uh it was
kind of like a Proto slasher that was
from 1972. he did a couple of political
Thrillers he did one called project kill
that had Leslie Nielsen in it of all
people and he did probably best known
for doing a couple of kind of like
Killer Animal like Eco horror type of
movies uh he did Grizzly from 1976 and
day of the animals uh from 1977 which is
a lot of fun if you haven't seen it now
the Manitou though
doesn't really fall into any of these
prior categories that I just uh
discussed this is kind of I'm not really
sure what genre you'd call it it's kind
of like a body horror movie sort of but
it also has kind of like Supernatural
overtones that were inspired by Native
American mythology specifically like
Algonquian mythology
okay it's got a pretty impressive cast
also uh you got the lead role is played
by you know the Hollywood legend Tony
Curtis also has some significant roles
for some other probably like actors
you'll probably recognize Michael ansara
who was actually a Lebanese actor
um and he played Native American
characters a lot as he does in this
movie but I actually recognized him from
The Buck Rogers TV show Buck Rogers in
the 25th Century and he was also
Commander Kang I think like on the
original Star Trek series and this movie
also has uh Susan Strasberg in it who
was kind of like a big it girl like back
in the 70s she was in the movie the trip
with Peter Fonda and she was also in a
couple episodes of Night Gallery that's
where I remembered her from and this
also has a cameo appearance by none
other than the legendary Burgess
Meredith he's only like in one scene but
it's a memorable one I'm gonna say that
now this movie starts out
relatively normally I'm gonna say um it
almost plays out a little bit like a
kind of amusing romantic drama comedy
dramedy if you want to call it that of
kind of the type that were popular back
then like in the 1970s
um you know albeit this one has a net
goiter involved which I'll get into in a
little bit but I'm gonna say that as the
movie goes on it gets pretty wacky
toward the end pretty wacky
um so much so that at one point I was
watching this movie and I kind of like
dozed off for a couple minutes because
you know I work long hours and it's you
know when you get old it's kind of hard
to stay awake for like a whole movie
especially if you got up really early so
I kind of dozed off for a few minutes
not very long and when I woke up I was
like so confused by what was going on in
the movie that I thought like maybe
somebody had dosed me or something I'm
like what the [__] is happening right
now like it seemed like it was kind of
normal leading up to this and then I was
just like it just went like Bonkers like
toward the end so now I wouldn't call
the Manitou a good movie by any stretch
of the imagination anything any
measurement that you would care to use
but it is a very very entertaining one
and there's just plenty of kind of what
the [__] moments in it for you to just
wonder at and enjoy so there's that so
at the beginning of the movie the movie
is actually set in uh San Francisco and
it was shot there as well
um we're following a woman named Karen
and she's not not like a Karen like that
name implies nowadays but she's just a
regular Karen now she's actually
Consulting a medical professional about
this kind of like disgusting growth
that's on her neck who knows see I told
you I would come back to the neck waiter
thing now she says that she first
noticed it three days ago and it's been
kind of like expanding growing at quite
an alarming rate uh since then she says
it doesn't hurt but she tells the doctor
something that should immediately send
up red flags she's like yeah sometimes
it moves around almost as though there's
something inside it that's like settling
into bed as though it's trying to become
more comfortable and you're just like uh
oh you know what I mean it's that kind
of situation
so the doctors tell her oh it's probably
nothing to be concerned about which you
know that's easy for them to say but
they schedule a surgery to remove it
like just in case but after she leaves
the doctors uh one of whom is actually
like a tumor specialist who I assume
they've brought in to like consult on
this case they kind of like privately
discussed between each other that's like
oh my God we've never seen anything like
this growth before and the tumor guy
specifically says whatever it is that
the x-rays because they x-rayed it they
said the x-rays are showing something
inside there that looks a little too
much like a fetus for comfort
now why they failed to tell the actual
patient any of this information is
really not explained but you know I mean
I guess
if you're a woman with a possibly
cancerous baby tumor like growing on
your body somewhere there's just really
no need for you to worry you're pretty
little pretty little woman ahead about
it I mean you know I'm sure the dudes
have it under control Karen though is no
dummy and she is pretty sure that the
doctors are not really giving her the
full picture about her condition now for
whatever reason
um she decides that the best course of
action now is to call Tony Curtis or at
least the character that he's playing in
this movie whose name is Harry Erskine I
think is his last name you find out
later that Karen actually used to work
with Harry and that they had you're
guessing like a prior romantic
relationship but haven't seen each other
in a really long time I don't know how
long it is but long enough we would see
like wow you're looking good I've seen
you in ages blah blah so it's that kind
of situation
now up to this point we've also kind of
been getting glimpses into Harry's life
as well now he actually makes his living
as this sort of like cheese dick fortune
teller
um reading tarot cards for like all of
these dottering rich old ladies that
like come to visit him like wanting
affirmation and things like that like
you know an advice on their love lives
and indigestion and various other things
um I actually these were kind of like
funny scenes so like like I said at the
beginning almost seems like a comedy
drama not a comedy comedy but it does
have like a lot of kind of work to do
like kind of quirky little uh tone like
that especially like with all of the
clients that are coming to see him and I
actually did like laugh out loud at one
point when Harry like he says goodbye to
his latest client and you're kind of let
they kind of implied that it's like a
prostitute that lives across the hall
because they kind of like have a little
exchange and I'm just like oh okay
so there's that
um but he sees off the old lady and
closes the door and then he peels his
fake mustache off it like sticks it on
the wall and then like he goes and puts
his normal clothes on and like has a
beer and everything like that I just I
don't know why I thought that was so
funny to me that like he just took off
his and he was like dude like you were
sticking gum on the bedpost or some [__]
like that I don't know that just really
made me laugh so when Karen calls him up
and wants to meet though I mean Harry is
immediately like oh yes ma'am whatever
like so he's immediately on board with
this so that implies to me that he's
still like carrying a torch for her you
know what I mean now it's not entirely
clear whether Karen called him because
she wanted him to tell her future like
in regards to the net growth and the
surgery that she's gonna have the next
day I mean because she does make it
obvious later that she doesn't really
believe any of this fortune telling [__]
or whether she's just missing some of
that sweet soothsang hairy dick you know
what I'm saying it could be both things
it could be both things I don't know so
anyway they meet up
and Harry he just he assures her
everything is going to be A-Okay with
the surgery even though his tarot cards
indicate otherwise so I will note that
this is another dude who is also keeping
crucial information from Karen you know
in in other words
so the pair of them then reconnect uh by
which I mean it's implied that they [__]
they don't really show it but you know
what I mean they both are at the house
and they both have robes on so I'm
assuming something happened there
um but while Karen is kind of like
sleeping in the in front of the
fireplace like on the bare skin rug I
don't think it was a bare skin rug but
you know what that was what I was
imagining anyway so she says this weird
phrase in her sleep that sounds
something like and I had the um closed
captioning on so it actually spelled it
out it sounds like Pana witchy salatu
which every time somebody said that in
the movie which was a lot of times
um I just kind of went like I just kind
of cringe I don't know it just sounds
very very cringy to me so the next
morning Harry is actually dropping her
off for the surgery and he asked her
about he's like what the [__] does that
mean like you said it in your sleep and
she's like I don't know I never heard
that before in my life and I don't
remember saying that so not too
surprisingly though uh the surgery does
not go so well um matter of fact it
actually doesn't go at all because as
soon as the doctor like puts the scalpel
on the growth like gonna cut it off
Karen's supposedly anesthetized eyes
like kind of pop open her heart rate
goes crazy and she's kind of like and
then the doctor actually slices his own
wrist like with the scalpel like he's
under some kind of overpowering mind
control or something like that so after
that Karen gets put back in her hospital
room and I'm presuming they sedate her
while the doctor's trying to figure out
like what the hell happened with that
meanwhile one of Harry's clients who's
this kind of flaky old woman named Mrs
hurts hurts hers something like that she
has some kind of like seizure during her
session with him and then she says the
same words that Karen said and then she
when she had like levitates out of the
room like levitates down the hallway of
the apartment building and then like
throws herself down the stairs like
where she presumably dies they never
really say that but you're presuming
that that she's dead
so Harry a little freaked out by this as
you probably would be he actually goes
to talk to the tumor doctor and after he
hears about what happened you know with
Karen's surgery he starts to become
convinced that whatever it is that is in
her neck growth is causing maybe some
kind of like psychic force to be
Unleashed like through her body I guess
essentially now naturally the doc does
not buy into this Theory um though he
does admit this whole situation is
pretty [__] weird and he's not really
sure what's going on so Harry decides
that he's going to kind of use his
connections on the you know spiritual
side of things because you know he's
kind of like a fortune teller to kind of
try and help Karen before this goiter
gets so big that it essentially like
consumes her or kills her or whatever so
the first thing he does he goes and
talks to this couple that he knows who
own this kind of like new AG type store
and they set up this Seance and they're
gonna ask the spirits about this entity
or whatever it is that's supposedly
possessing Karen so
um actually this is the movie's best
effect probably because when they have
the Seance this like freaky looking dude
like emerges from the middle of the
Seance table like it almost looks like
he's coming out of like a pool of oil
like it's all black and it's like the
they show his face like an extreme
close-up and it's this kind of like oily
black kind of thing going on and it's
like really cool now he doesn't say
anything that anybody can understand
he's like speaking in some unknown
language but because the the medium at
the Seance says that he reminds her of
one of those you know cigar store Indian
type things like they used to have you
know like old Chief wooden head and the
Stephen King story like that kind of
thing so he says well since he kind of
looks like that
um they kind of deduce that maybe
whatever this thing is this entity is is
like some kind of being from Native
American folklore
so the group of them then actually go to
visit Burgess Meredith who is playing
this kind of Colonel Sanders looking
Anthropologist who's named Dr Hughes and
he wrote a book about Native American
folklore and he mentioned a thing called
title drop the Manitou now this is
essentially kind of like a life force
from what I can understand from like
that certain powerful medicine men could
use to essentially be reborn in
different bodies like which would cause
them to live forever I mean at least
according to the stories right
um Dr Hughes also tells them that that
phrase Panda witchy salad too which like
I said is making me cringe every time I
say it
um actually means my death foretells my
return which
doesn't make a lot of sense if you
really think about it but whatever
um so yeah so he doesn't actually
believe any of these Legends are true
obviously he's an anthropologist he's
not you know into the new agey kind of
[__]
um but he does suggest that you know the
Scooby gang go and talk to an actual
Medicine Man and like you know leave me
the [__] alone pretty much so at this
stage in the story Harry actually goes
to visit this movie's magical Native
American which you know a lot of movies
back then had one uh and this guy's name
is John singing Rock and he's uh
initially pretty cranky
um but he eventually grudgingly agrees
to help Harry's pasty white ass in
exchange for some tobacco and a 100
000 donation to like a specific Native
American charity
where Harry got his hands on a hundred
grand is not ever explained um he
doesn't even bat an eye when the guy
says this so I'm assuming he's got like
some good Investments or he's kin to the
Rockefellers or something but he's like
hey hundred thousand dollars hey no
problem you know what I mean I was just
like holy [__] [__] and this was like
the 1970s so that was like a lot more
money back then
so John's singing rock is actually able
to communicate with this entity that's
growing inside Karen's net goiter which
is a sentence I never thought that I
would say out loud but here we are and
uh so the entity actually reveals that
he's a shaman named misquamakis now
misquamakis fun fact is actually a
character from the August durleth novel
from 1945 which is called the lurker at
the threshold which was based on
unfinished writings by you guessed it HP
Lovecraft so if you see the book
nowadays it usually says HP Lovecraft
with August or listen you know what I
mean poor Augusto but yeah but I mean HP
Lovecraft like left a bunch of stuff
like after he died in August duralith
like finished it out and so the lurker
at the threshold he's a character in
that mystical Marcus so misko Marcus is
actually like pretty annoyed by this
whole uh you know white man wiping out
the indigenous people's deal and he's
decided that he's going to possess
Karen's body so he can return and like
take revenge why he chose Karen in
particular is never clarified
um and it's also not clear why
misquamakis waited so long like to come
back and like kick some Caucasian ass
um I don't really know me I'm sure he
was busy doing something else and I
don't know what that was but you know
what I mean he's he'd eventually just
decided he's just kind of a lazy bomb
but he's just like you know what I'm
still mad I'm gonna I'm gonna possess
some random woman and come back and and
do some [__] so it's at this juncture
where the movie Just cranks up the level
of batshittery like 211 and just goes
pretty much like balls to the wall
banana pants like for the remainder of
the runtime so basically misquamakis
busts out of Karen's net goiter yeah she
heard that correctly
um he kind of looks like this little
naked brown dwarf with these crazy like
loony eyes and he just starts pulling
all kind of like Paranormal Shenanigans
um he for example uh telekinetically
Cuts up John's face with scalpels like
off screen you just see like the outcome
of that also freezes the hospital
hallway for some reason including
freezing the hapless uh receptionist
that's out there uh her Frozen head
actually breaks off later so that's fun
also at one point he six a process shot
of a giant lizard uh at our heroes so
there's that kind of stuff too
so after all of this [__] happens
John uh tells Harry you know miscomakis
he's just way too powerful for me to
fight and although the demon is
temporarily put out of commission by
Harry like hefting a typewriter in him
so
uh but you know in spite of that yeah he
he's for real like too powerful vagina
to fight so Harry at this point gets a
little bit frustrated with John's kind
of defeatist attitude so he wonders
whether the manitou's manatees Mana what
is the I don't know what the I don't
even know if that would be like um would
have like a plural I'm not really sure
but he's saying whether the manatees
inside all the hospitals machines might
somehow kind of be harnessed to battle
misquamakis which what like I I don't
know and I don't think like I said I did
doze off like for a couple of minutes
but I'm pretty sure I didn't miss
anything where that was set up where
it's like oh well I guess the
implication is that everything like even
um inanimate objects have a Manitou like
have a life force so I get that but I
don't know if that was adequately set up
because it just seems like he kind of
pulls it out of his butt oh didn't you
say like doesn't this Hospital have like
super high-tech machines yeah so well
couldn't the manitou's from those
machines like couldn't we call on them
to like fight the demon or whatever I'm
just like what the [__] are you even
talking about like how did you even get
that idea I don't know but anyway so
they do it like they give this bizarre
plant a spin right but apparently
the collective life forces of you know
the EKG machines and the ventilators and
all that kind of stuff don't want to
help the white people either so now it
looks like in something that kind of
reminded me a little bit of like Altered
States or something like that it kind of
looks like Karen's hospital room is like
floating in this void like in the far
reaches of outer space or whatever and
against this backdrop you have like the
final battle royale so misquamakis is
kind of like over there like snickering
and like throwing Fireballs at everybody
and you know like Harry and John are
like ducking them then the machine
manitou's are in there like chastising
John for helping Whitey and then there's
this like kind of an old great one or
something like that it looks like a
weird big light eyeball thing so there's
that so yeah so they're fighting and
like it looks like they're losing but
then Harry decides he calls to Karen to
fight back um so Karen finally like sits
up in her bed because that [__] has
just been like her lazy bum ass has just
been laying there in the bed the whole
time like while this whole ordeal is
going on and I'm just like yeah why
don't you get up and tribute this is all
because of you you know so yeah so she
finally like sits up and she starts like
chucking magical lightning balls like
back at the demon also I'm pretty sure
at this point where she's doing this
she's naked although she wasn't before
and she isn't afterward either
um and it's kind of hard to tell because
of like all the darkness and the flying
light beams and whatnot but I thought I
saw some boobies there so I don't know
if like I guess only naked ladies can
fight demons in the movie's universe or
whatever I mean if that's the rules then
okay fair enough but I'm I'm pretty sure
I saw boobs I'm just saying it's not
like right in your face and I think like
one of the movie posters too like had
her kind of naked like from the side so
I'm guessing yeah she was naked but like
I said she wasn't before and she was
after so whatever it was just very
random so I guess that uh Karen's you
know Pink Floyd laser light show that
she had going there and maybe her like
bare breastage
um were just too much for mystical
markets to handle because he kind of
like disappears in a big [__]
explosion or whatever
um I think it's mentioned that Harry's
love for Karen was able to defeat the
evil when everything else failed or
whatever but I'm not really sure like
the logistics of how all of that works
and that wasn't really even set up
either but anyway so miscal mock is he
gets beaten back along with the great
old one thing he was kind of backing him
up everything goes back to normal again
even though John's singing Rock says
that misco Marcus isn't really dead he's
just kind of like temporarily sidelined
um you know so I guess I mean the demon
seemed pretty hell-bent on Revenge
though so I'm guessing it probably won't
be all that long before he decides to
install himself in someone else's bodily
protuberance in order to like be born
again just be busting out of [__]
[__] you know zit somewhere so uh you
know have those moles and swellings
checked people you never know you got
some Algonquin like [__] Troublemaker
skulking around inside your [__]
inside your moles and whatnot uh so yeah
as I mentioned blink the Mana two it's
not a great film okay it's it's pretty
silly it's completely unbelievable and
kind of uh just pulls the mythology
right out of its butt like whenever it's
convenient but I have to say that it's
pretty [__] enjoyable like for all of
that it's just overtly ridiculous and it
actually has some decent special effects
for the time
and it just has this real sense of just
complete absurdity like you're watching
it going what the [__] is happening now
and like you can't believe like it's
just going so balls to the wall and
everybody's taking it so seriously that
it's just like becomes over the top like
really really funny now I've actually
never read the book I don't think I have
so I don't know how accurate an
adaptation it is I would Hazard a guess
that the source novel probably took
itself a lot more seriously and probably
made a hell of a lot more sense in
context but if you've read it like let
me know because I'm kind of curious so
I'm gonna say if you just you know one
random day you kind of find yourself in
the mood for some strange Supernatural
craziness from that shameful decade of
the 1970s then uh you know give it a
watch it is actually like it's kind of
terrible but it's also kind of a lot of
fun just because of how [__] nutty it
is and you're just like you're like what
the [__] were they even thinking and how
do they even come up with this with this
[__] and it's just like really
really funny because like I said
everyone's still like taking it very
very seriously but yeah so if if you
have shutter at least as of this
recording which is May of 2023 um it's
actually on shutter so if you have that
like you can watch it on there and if
you've seen it like let me know what you
thought about it or like I said if
you've read the book like let me know
how similar it is or if they completely
changed it or whatever because I'm kind
of curious about that so that will do it
for this flickers of fear hope you guys
enjoyed it please remember to like share
and comment and I will see you guys
again on the next one bye